[Music]
[Applause]
Paul Finebaum ESPN radio host the Paul
feinbaum show the voice of the SEC
always great to have you back Paul
thanks for making time how about a loss
was that for Tennessee big picture was
it wasn't cataclysmic Dan because if
Tennessee can get some help and they've
already gotten a lot with Clemson losing
uh they could be back in this thing
pretty quickly what they need quite
frankly is is TCU to lose which I think
a lot of people think is very possible
and and then it becomes a beauty contest
is it Tennessee is it Oregon coming out
of the West and you know Tennessee has a
very impressive win right now that we
didn't think was all that impressive
when they went down to Baton Rouge a
couple weeks ago and destroyed LSU
that's going to help them a lot and the
LSU Alabama I it's a gutsy call there I
don't know how good Alabama is and I
know you've said this before like we're
seeing Nick Saban get out coached that's
strong to say for the greatest coach of
all time but why do you believe that
I believe it because uh I've seen four
games this year uh that have come down
to the wire savings team has won two and
lost to in every one it was the feeling
of me which is what you're asking here
um that that the other guy did a better
job uh he he's been pretty much a
double-digit favorite in all these games
uh Steve sarkeesian going back to the
Texas game I had a master of a plan so
did Jimbo Fisher uh came down to a about
a two-yard play at the end that Alabama
stopped them and then heifel uh really
wiped the floors with saving up in
Knoxville a couple weeks ago and Brian
Kelly outmaneuvered him as well and Dan
we both know this is subjective but I
think we grade saving on on a Mount
Rushmore type scale even when it's a
close call he's going to get the tie
well he's getting the loss right now
and you go back to that loss to Florida
State by LSU and people were crushing
Brian Kelly and his accent when he uh
you know appeared at the basketball game
I he can have a Cajun accent today it
doesn't matter it feels like LSU he he
wouldn't beat Alabama if he was at Notre
Dame being at LSU gives him the chance
to beat Alabama
well Dan he has said repeatedly that he
left Notre Dame so he could beat Nick
Saban uh he took care of that in one
shot and and you understand this because
you're deep into college football but to
LSU Nick Saban is everything he used to
coach there he won a national
championship there in 2003 and that's
the first time in that stadium in in in
a Death Valley that LSU Was Won since
2010
uh that was just at the the onset of
less miles run remember him uh and and
it's really significant and you know
Brian Kelly uh got a lot of hate and not
only did he were people making fun of
him because of his accent Notre Dame
people just trashed him as you know and
it's uh listen you you walk away from
something like that and you think you
have something better in Marcus Freeman
and maybe maybe Marcus Freeman can lead
them to a national championship he had a
pretty significant win Saturday night
but but Kelly didn't care at 61 he said
you know what I'll go make 10 million
dollars and get to eat the best Cajun
food in the world
you got a situation with Clemson it's
not the same as when they had like Kelly
Bryant and then you know you're you're
gonna bring in Trevor Lawrence because
you got a you know generational Talent
it doesn't feel like DJ is is that
starting quarterback there but I don't
know if the you know the Freshman behind
him is
he's he's not a generational talent but
I wonder if that's what's holding
Clemson back
I think a lot of things are holding
Clemson back and again they could end up
the season 11 or 12 and one and some
people would look back at this
conversation and think I'm crazy uh they
know you are yeah
um and but you know Clemson plays in a
in a league that that doesn't generate a
lot of Buzz anymore so they come it
comes down to usually a one or two game
seasons and they lost and they lost
badly and I think I think Dabo Sweeney
has been hurt badly uh by the way he's
handled coordinators he's lost two
really good coordinators uh two other
schools one one got fired yesterday so
he may be back soon uh and he lost Brent
venables who who it was a generational
defensive coordinator to go to Oklahoma
not sure that was a good idea either uh
and and he he he he he he gave guys uh
raises he he upped them he he hired from
within internally so I I think that was
a questionable call but that's fabulous
Sweeney and the problem at at Clemson uh
when they don't make the playoffs it's
like Alabama it's considered a disaster
of season and I think tomorrow night
when and I know you're waiting eagerly
uh for both the election results and the
cfp reveal but this will be the first
time I think uh in the history of the
cfp since 2014 that you don't have
Alabama or Clemson in there
more likely to make the playoffs TCU or
Oregon
I think it's TCU if you know because I
think that they can let me use the
cliche of the of the of the year uh
control their own destiny uh because if
TCU wins the Big 12 uh and and even with
one loss they might have an argument
Oregon's problem uh is a 46 Point loss
to Georgia and I know in the idea that
Bo Nick said well I think we'd have a
much better game against them now as an
understatement of course they of course
they would uh that was Dan lanning's
first game uh but you know think about
Georgia Georgia has probably the two
best wins in the country uh to this year
against Oregon and against uh Tennessee
Saturday uh so I think Oregon has to
hope for a lot of things and and hoping
that that they I don't think they can
outdo Tennessee even though you'll hear
the nonsensical uh chairman of the
committee talk on Tuesday night that we
value the uh that extra value point to
the to the conference Championship I
don't think winning uh even this year
when the pack draws a little bit better
winning that league is going to help
them enough could Ohio State and
Michigan both make the playoffs
uh yeah probably more likely if Michigan
wins because Ohio state does at least
have a non-conference schedule Michigan
doesn't although I'm I'm I was all in on
Ohio State Dan you're going to have to
help me being a Big Ten expert and I'm
not but some of my friends are starting
to warn me off picking Ohio State in
that game Michigan is holding up quite
well
well I think when you saw the
Northwestern game and you're like okay I
know the weather was not great I just
know Ohio state has great players in
Northwestern doesn't have great players
so the weather was the same for both
teams it didn't rain when Ohio state was
playing offense there that was a little
bit surprising Paul feinbaum the ESPN
radio host uh the possibility of San
Diego State joining the Pac-12
what do you think um
how do you see the the the reshaping of
the Pac-12 if it is true that USC and
UCLA are going to leave
yeah and and I I don't think we're done
yet either uh you know there's a lot of
bad blood between the Big 12 and the
Pac-12 not that that's really going to
make anyone care uh but but I I'm not
sure the the big 12 is done yet I think
they're going to still make a run at
some of those Pac-12 schools and I don't
think the the Big Ten is done yet either
uh Dan and I know you're always putting
out nuggets so I hate to even even go
down in into your neighborhood here but
I I feel like they're they're just
letting the dust settle uh and I still
think they've got their eyes on some
perhaps more Pac-12 schools yeah I
wonder what Oregon does
yeah I mean you look at Oregon and
Washington they're I think they were I
mean they're natural geographical uh fit
to the pack to the big to the Big Ten
now I mean I think right now none of
that matters I mean we used to talk 10
15 years ago TV footprint that doesn't
matter in in the streaming world and and
I think Amazon remains a major player
here uh to to help supplement the Big
Ten I I frankly think the Big Ten will
perhaps go after Oregon and Washington
before before they're done but I wonder
if you're Oregon why not stay in the
Pac-12 if you know if you run the
schedule there an easier route to play
in the playoffs now once we expand to 12
that's a little different but with only
four I would want to stay there I guess
bigger picture you know you would go
where you could make more money and
you're going to get a playoff spot if
there's 12. but Dan we are going to to a
12 sometime as soon as this Committee of
of of geniuses you know stops talking
about how difficult it is it could come
as early as 24. I think it will come no
later than 25. so all these moves will
will be uh super will be will supersede
that so I think you everyone is just
getting set up because once you once we
have a 12-team playoff you can play a
Big Ten schedule an SEC schedule it
doesn't really matter you can lose two
or three games and you're still factored
into the equation
is North Carolina as good as their
uniforms look
uh the quarterback is I don't think they
are
um and I get I'm really happy for mag
Brown I mean because we were all writing
him off last year saying he was too old
he was 70 years old but and he has come
back with a really nice season here uh
unfortunately uh he'll play in an ACC
Championship game that will be about as
Off-Broadway as you can get
um against Clemson and but but it's
still North Carolina and uh they have
great uniforms in basketball and
football
and Drake May from what I'm told uh you
know by a store said teams will tank for
Drake May when he becomes eligible he's
that good
I think he is and you think about he's
getting the most out of out of this
season while going back to Alabama for a
second I I really feel like Brett Bryce
young has wasted uh an incredible year I
mean Bryce young had a play
in the LSU game that would have been a
Heisman moment if his defense could stop
anyone uh but any and he had the same
plays in in the Tennessee game I mean he
is playing as good as he did last year
including the sprained shoulder but
we're already writing him off because of
the he's got a leaky defense always
great to talk to you uh which fan base
do you think will be the angriest or
saddest today on your show
um I'm betting everything on Alabama
fans today uh there's nothing there's
nothing like a meltdown after the first
Alabama loss but the second Alabama
lawsuit it's as close to Armageddon as
you can get that's good thank you Paul
always great to talk to you thank you
Dan that's Paul Finebaum ESPN radio host
host of the Paul Finebaum show and the
voice of the SEC